it is time to get cooking with manny
bubby thanks to chapman automotive who
is sponsoring this segment of course
today she's showing us how to make a
delicious taco charcuterie board
and of course this is something going
viral on all social media and the
internet
and i have never seen it done so i'm
excited
oh my god and i am actually looking
forward to you kind of calling it out
and
helping me out i'd love to the idea
actually
good this idea actually came to me by
one of the members
of nanny bubby's facebook group which is
gather with nanny bubbe
she actually became a member rocky after
watching you and me and then she googled
it and found it her facebook big
search and i thought it was i know
i know and i thought it was so cute but
the word taco charcuterie just didn't go
because i think of a charcuterie board
as being
meats and cheese and french and italian
and rice
and that's what's bible right now
yes and the word char charcuterie
shar means meat and coot means cooked so
any meat that is cooked makes the
charcuterie board
so before we assemble it together i just
want to bring you over here i want to
show you one little recipe hack
for mexican street corn and
then we'll just get over here and put it
all together so
this is an ear of corn and i started it
already but
in order to get all the silk off and get
it out of the husk
this is what you do you put it in the
microwave completely sealed not
cut for four minutes when it's done
still hot
and steaming which this one is you cut
off the stem
and then you just literally start
squeezing
and as you squeeze it comes right out no
silk
at all how do you like that you got all
the then the next thing you do
is put it yeah all the moves huh you
should see me dance
and then here we go you put it in a
bundt can with the narrow piece and just
cut down
the bundt pan catches all that fabulous
corner doesn't go
everywhere just turn and keep cutting
and that is the hack
this goes into a saute pan
with red peppers green peppers green
onions and garlic
and it is the star of the show so we're
gonna put it in the dish in your
prettiest dish
which is in the center all the way on
you're already on your board
put that corn right in we'll put a
little spoon in there for those that
want it
and we're going to start to assemble so
here's the one thing rocky
those things that are going to be on
your board meaning that they're not
in little cups and plates like i have
them here
those things you put on first and now
you assemble
everything else around it so to you my
friend
what do you like on your tacos oh okay
obviously
meat is there meat okay what options do
we have
how about so we have chicken
smoked chicken we have the beef right
and then right here we have okay
with chicken and shrimp so we'll put
those right here so
what you want to do is put your meats
into one area okay
and then we're going to our how about
our guacamole you like guacamole
that is my favorite yes load it on load
it off
okay there's tomato guacamole and then
the
okay here we got the tomatoes from the
pico de gallo right over here
right black beans cheese right here my
friend how about that how good does that
look can't do it
and how about just kind of squeeze it
all in no how about a little bit of
lettuce for you oh
absolutely right yeah there we go and
cilantro right notice this is an anaheim
pepper already cut and swirled just like
that with the
cilantro right there and then set some
limes just kind of tuck those limes
right in i have a line here a little bit
later for that
that tequila that we're gonna you know
yeah there you go
there you go and how about red onion are
you liking that you know okay i'm gonna
say my bedroom
but you go ahead and do it okay all
right
oh no i can't do it believe me i'd be up
for three nights okay how about some
queso cheese
of course that makes it absolutely
fabulous
and a little bit of sour cream which
will take the heat off perfect
of the jalapenos and the red and green
peppers and look how beautiful and
colorful
this is there we have it i have about 30
seconds left yep and
of course we have well we've got
a lime and a shot of tequila do i dare
tequila
come on now oh it's right here
i'll do it for you nanny bubby cheers
yeah there you go oh my god
do you know what it's actually it's
actually water but i thought it would
make great television so there you go
okay fine stay hydrated great weekend
thank you so much nanny bubby spread
love like buddy you can check out nanny
bubby's kitchen and garden
on social media and online at
nannybubby.com thank you to chapman
automotive for sponsoring this fun
segment